the Joe Rogan experience but I think I'm
far enough out of getting hot like I got
it's the drugs are finally out of my
[ __ ] system there's other drugs they
give you that are basically legal dope
they're just thing called suboxone and
losing an opiate blocker but it's dope
you know the duty
it stops you from getting high on heroin
but it stops the withdrawals too so you
also get high you know it's an opioid
yeah but it's legal and so if you're on
what they call some box and maintenance
you uh you can pee with that in your
urine and you'll be all right if they
know you're on it but you're getting huh
through a doctor you're getting I it's
like methadone right method no we don't
have these guys that would come to the
pool wall we'd call the methadone Ian's
yeah they would go down the street
they'd get their methadone it comes to
poolhall need to be zombies ok another
story about methadone for a little while
I took methadone at a methadone clinic
while I was on Howard cuz I was
desperately trying to get off heroin but
look again the only diversity methadone
and heroin is legality late like one so
the courts are cool with one for some
reason and the other one is illegal I
mean if you have no legal issues why not
just keep doing heroin it makes no
[ __ ] sense probably like better for
you
heroin is the one drug that doesn't
affect any organ like the way people die
on heroin is you you overdose but like
look at Keith Richards I mean he just
got good [ __ ] he got pure [ __ ] yeah and
he never od'd and died so like he's
almost preserved it kind of doesn't
affect your liver nothing like that no
so there's no real health consequences
other than over other than really other
than OD and and the withdrawals because
it becomes a part of your body is it
like it's it's again I'm not
recommending it it's a living hell I'm
it's more it's a living out the
lifestyle and the people that get into
your life because of it but so a couple
of times I went to a methadone clinic
that opened at 6:00 a.m. because the guy
was a fan of Stern he would let me come
into the methadone clinic at 5:30 and
get I took a [ __ ] they give it to you an
orange juice okay take a shot of orange
juice with the methadone twice I threw
up on the air and one time again I was
funnier off the [ __ ] than this Howard
was talking I think was Roseanne Barr
and Howard said how you look thin she
was on the phone and I'm nauseous like
listen to this timing I'm nauseous when
the left I feel like I'm gonna throw up
and I got a live mic you know right and
and she goes oh yeah Howard I've been
exercising and he goes what even do it
she goes well I get in I get in a a
two-piece bathing suit now as soon as
she said that you know as soon as and
how is what I was doing it to be funny
go sure what are you doing I go yeah as
soon as she said I get a two-piece but
my comedic timing was better so so so
now doing that for a while and but at
that point I know legally so what the
[ __ ] am I even trying this for right you
know
[Applause]